bonsoir nouvelle édition du journal sur
tv fil 78 nous sommes le 20 avril et
pour débuter retour sur ce spectacle
d'ismaël saïdi ce belge de 39 ans
raconte depuis plus d'un an avec humour
la radicalisation de trois jeunes de ses
compatriotes puis leur départ pour la
syrie avant d'évoquer leur
désenchantement vendredi dernier il
était à trappes devant quelques 300
lycéens de la plaine de neauphle c'est
la première fois que ce spectacle était
joué devant un public scolaire depuis
les tragiques événements de paris et de
bruxelles
le reportage de sephora namani jihad
l'histoire de reda ben et ismaël trois
jeunes belges est originaire de
molenbeek partant rejoindre la syrie
sans qu'aucun d'eux n'est lu le coran
un spectacle tragi-comique écrit en 2014
par ismaël saïdi pour ces enfants qui ne
devait voir initialement que cinq
représentations et pourtant la 136e a eu
lieu à la mairie ce de trappe devant 300
jeunes du lycée de la plaine 2 nov
vendredi 15 avril il ya vraiment une
rupture identitaire chez ces trois
personnages et c'est ça qu'on parle dans
cette pièce on n'a surtout pas voulu
être mangé mon réalisateur avec ce
spectacle met juste en tout cas de
pouvoir réfléchir chercher à comprendre
comment voilà quelqu'un qui n'est ici en
europe et un moment donné qu est ce qui
peut se passer dans votre tête pour vous
dire je vais aller me tuer allez mourir
en martyr on est dans une guerre sainte
qu'on arrive à vous faire avaler des
choses mais que toutes les trois grandes
religions monothéistes
condamne reconnue d'utilité publique par
le ministère de l'éducation belge la
pièce a été représentée devant plus de
50000 spectateurs dont vingt-cinq mille
jeunes invités par rachid benzine
attrape la représentation scolaire était
une première en france un débat mené par
l'auteur et l'islamologue a suivi le
spectacle pour libérer la parole chez
les lycéens
j'ai eu l'occasion ici à trappes là où
j'habite de parler d'un coup devant les
professeurs et ensuite une journée avec
les élèves et j'ai senti que cette
question du jihad
la question de l'identité la question de
la construction de la construction la
question même de l'islam pose problème
pourquoi on organise un spectacle comme
ça c'est précisément pour que des élèves
se pose des questions et c'est de
chercher des réponses sur des questions
qui les occupent
l'éducation nationale c'est enseigner
les enseignants savent faire ça mais il
faut aussi que les jeunes puissent
s'interroger dialoguer discuter
le spectacle a remporté l'adhésion
générale des lycéens qui ont pu passer
pour certains des rires aux larmes et la
réflexion quant à elle a pu être
enrichie en classe grâce à un livret
pédagogique créé autour de la pièce
social à présent une vingtaine de
doctorants de l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines qui se sont
réunis en début de semaine pour dénoncer
leur statut qu'ils jugent précaire selon
eux deux tiers des emplois de plusieurs
services de l'université de versailles
50 ans serait décédé d où des vacataires
non rémunérés pour la plupart des
missions qu'ils exécutent comme la
préparation des cours ou encore la
correction des copies l'objectif de
cette mobilisation
sensibiliser le public à leur situation
situation qu'il souhaite aussi faire
connaître en interpellant leur direction
dans les jours à venir alors que
l'élection du nouveau président doit se
faire le 10 mai prochain à écouter l'un
des membres du collectif des précaires
moi par exemple ça fait sept mois que
j'enseigne ici ssh et on ne sait
toujours pas mon statut ou est ce qu'il
en est mon dossier est ce que je vais te
rémy est normalement oui bien sûr mais
les heures sont toujours pas validés et
bien sûr sur notre et trébuchantes là on
est encore bien loin d'avoir reçu
le paiement pour ce service ensuite il
yal'absence aussi de contrat de travail
pareil c'est à dire le cadre même
législatif minimum légal minimum qui
relie ce statut là il est présent au
mieux après la tâche effectuée et ça
pour l'instant
moi j'ai fini mon premier sonné j'ai
entamé le second et j'ai toujours pas de
contrat de travail là dessus
pareil une troisième contradiction
encore forte on veut souligner à
laquelle on voudrait mettre un terme
c'est de fait de devoir payer des les
frais d'inscription pour pouvoir venir
ici enseigne et nous on n'est plus
derrière les bancs de la fac on est
devant c'est à dire combien pour
enseigner aux bénéfices plus court ou de
formation c'est au stade pierre de
coubertin à paris que pierre bédier le
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines a rencontré le président de la
fondation psg l'objectif de ce
rendez-vous signé la prolongation de la
convention entre les deux institutions
jusqu'en 2017 le club va pouvoir à
travers cet organisme poursuivre son
engagement auprès des jeunes des clubs
de l'ouest francilien une rencontre qui
était accompagné avec 2 en valeurs
vedettes devant mille jeunes de cette
fondation william l c'est une histoire
qui dure depuis maintenant quinze ans le
19 avril à paris pierre bédier nasser
al-khelaifi se sont rencontrées pour la
signature d'une convention liant le
département des yvelines à la fondation
psg un engagement en faveur de la
jeunesse qui se poursuivra jusqu'en 2017
c'est une tradition puisque les yvelines
ont été à quasiment à l'origine un
partenaire de cette fondation et à cette
tradition c'est la tradition de
solidarité
il faut que les sportifs de haut niveau
soit un exemple mais un exemple concret
et donc qu'ils aillent vers les plus
jeunes vers les plus faibles pour leur
apporter du plaisir du bonheur et puis
les inciter au 6e même à regarder vers
le 10 sportifs foot humain
la karabatic et daniel narcisse après
leur sacre de champion de france sous
les couleurs du psg handball souvenu
enflammé le stade devant mille jeunes de
la fondation
c'est important pour le club après avoir
tancé pour nous les joueurs de voir à
travers la fondation donner un peu notre
temps pour les enfants pour les enfants
en difficulté sociale et les voilà ce
qu'on ait d'autres non
ça fait vraiment chaud au coeur la
fondation avec un autre partenaire j'ai
fiba ils ont réussi à réaliser une super
belle journée où on voit l'enthousiasmé
enfants les gamins sont super contents
d'être là ils peuvent pratiquer salaires
en vacances mais le fait de pouvoir leur
proposer une journée comme ça c'est 200
yvelinois étaient présents sur cette
journée un contrat qui permet surtout
aux jeunes lillois de la fondation de
continuer à bénéficier des activités
mises en place
quand ça clairefontaine engagement sur
le handicap ou invitations aux
entraînements privés
mais aujourd'hui il ne fallait pas
oublier que psg ne rime pas qu'avec
football
si vous habitez à montigny le bretonneux
ils vous ont peut-être déjà rendu visite
depuis le 4 avril des ambassadeurs du
tri y vont à la rencontre désigné mon
teint pour les aider les conseiller à
mieux trier bonsoir mélanie qui sont ces
ambassadeurs alors cessons assad vers
son sein qui sont âgés de 19 à 31 ans la
commune de montigny-le-bretonneux a voté
le 14 décembre 2015 un plan de relance
pour le recyclage l'action de ces
ambassadeurs est basée sur un
partenariat qu eco emballages qui
finance notamment le poste d ambassadeur
la commune elle a décidé de cibler
principalement les zones d'habitat
collectif
bruno bout ce soir l'adjoint au maire
nous en explique les raisons
s'ils ont le mauvais gestes qui font un
mauvais tri ils vont polluer le bac
jaune et du coup ce sont tout de suite
des grandes quantités alors qu'en zone
pavillonnaire le l'habitant et d'un bac
pour deux trois personnes mais en
collectif le bas qui fait 660 clip et du
coup il
il accueille les objets de plusieurs
familles
la commune de montigny le bretonneux ce
sont plus de trente quatre mille
habitants en déchets recyclables ça
représente quoi
alors sur l'année 2014 les imminente ont
trié 7 182 tonnes de verre soit à peu
près 23 kg par habitant
il crée aussi plus de 1300 tonnes
d'emballages de journaux de magazines ou
encore de bouteilles en plastique et là
ça fait à peu près 40 7 kg par habitant
et les ambassadeurs sont présents
jusqu'au mois de juin jusqu'aux vacances
sur la ville de montigny et vont les
rencontrer également ses habitants ils
vont les rencontres et sont à tous les
jours du lundi au vendredi ils font du
porte à porte dans les habitations
collectives comme je disais ça
représente à peu près dix mille foyers
il passe entre 16h et 19h30 c'est les
habitants sont informés en cas d'absence
il faut un second passage et lors de
leur visite ils proposent aux aînés
monte à un petit questionnaire pour
cibler les erreurs de recyclage mais
aussi ça permet de faire remonter à la
commune les besoins des habitants
les difficultés qu'ils rencontrent pour
trier mais avant d'être sur le terrain
ils ont été formés fanny camiade est
l'une de ces ambassadrices
on les écoute pareco gestique on a eu
une première journée de formation
voilà avec tout ce qui est en
problématique enjeux du déchet en juin
par rapport à l'environnement
quels sont les différents acteurs
quelles sont les filières de recyclage
qui existe enfin un petit rappel en gros
et après on a eu également une journée
de formation en communication
interpersonnelle on commission verbale
et non verbale
donc ils viennent nous expliquer si on a
encore des doutes après alors si on a
encore des doutes ils remettent un sac
de pré tri et un mémo les habitants
peuvent s'y référer au moindre doute et
puis depuis deux ans le tri est
facilitée parce que eco emballages a mis
en place de nouvelles signalétiques
on nous dit carrément ce qui va à la
poubelle ce qui va dans la poubelle de
tri pour mieux expliquer les habitants
pour les aider à mettre dans la poubelle
va c'est pas possible on a dépassé le
logo en fait ce qui facilite beaucoup le
tri le déplacement des ambassadeurs
c'est quand même mieux faciliter le tri
mais c'est aussi sensibiliser et là
c'est laura caburet qui elle aussi
ambassadrice qui nous l'expliquent va le
fait de trier c'est
ça va économiser les matières premières
en fait vu qu'on peut leurrer employés
faire de nouvelles de nouvelles par amp
si vous voulez je vous donne un exemple
des bouteilles en verre ou en plastique
ça va devenir vendre des paillettes et
en fait on peut refaire des couettes ou
tout ce qui est au niveau de la
réutilisation de recyclage
alors après le passage de ces 100 bahts
de ses ambassadeurs des ambassadeurs
dans saw 6 ambassadrice la commune elle
réalisera ce qu'ils appellent des
caractérisations trois résidences ont
été ciblés trois fois avant le début de
l'opération
elles le seront à nouveau trois fois
après le mois de juin pour les animaux
les indie montant qui ne sont pas
présents lors de la visite ou qui sont
en habitat individuel il y aura des
rendez-vous dans plusieurs maisons de
quartier voilà vraiment c'est on donne
la main à chacun pour bien trier ses
déchets sur cette ville de montigny
c'est jusqu'au mois de juin en tout cas
merci à mélanie nous poursuivons ce
journal avec un tout autre sujet c'est
la fête de la bière ce qui n'a
absolument rien à voir
rendez vous qui se déroule tous les deux
ans à bois d'arcy c'était le week-end
dernier les images sont signés william
el est le reportage est écrit par
guillaume le squer accordéon et habits
folkloriques au programme de la 9e
édition de la fête de la bière de bois
d'arcy organisée par le comité de
jumelage cette fête célèbre l'amitié
entre les arcisien et les habitants de
leur ville jumelle michel en allemagne
c'est important en ces temps un peu
difficile il faut faire des efforts pour
rapprocher les gens les uns des autres
ça c'est effectivement un des objectifs
c'était un des objectifs également du
comité de jumelage c'est aussi
effectivement pour faire un peu ou
connaître michel n'est pas totalement
leur donner envie d'y aller puisque on
va y aller en octobre dans le cadre du
comité des menaces depuis 2000
l'événement se tient tous les deux ans
il fédère habitués et curieux on pouvait
compter 250 participants samedi dernier
et parmi eux 50 allemand nous
connaissons la fête de la bière depuis
de nombreuses années c'est toujours un
grand plaisir pour nous de venir ici
tous les deux ans il ya quelques
nouveaux à s'être joint à nous pour
faire le voyage jusqu'à bois d'arcy mais
parmi les 50 allemands présents
aujourd'hui il y en a beaucoup qui
viennent depuis de nombreuses années
déjà des habitants qui avait amené
spécialement 300 litres de bière pour
l'occasion elle est plutôt banal petit
goût petite amertume mais pas trop et
ça sent le houblon le houblon de de
l'est
ce soir on va essayer de voir manger des
choco bien boire et puis après on verra
les participants ont pu se retrouver et
échanger autour de la traditionnelle
choucroute et en profitant d'animations
sans oublier le passage exceptionnel de
madeline une des plus jeunes
accordéonistes de france
le comité de jumelage de bois d'arcy
prépare déjà la dixième édition de son
événement rendez vous donc en 2018
m
et bien sûr tout ça avec modération
comme le veut la formule consacrée on se
retrouve demain aux horaires habituels
pour un nouveau point sur l'actualité
locale très belle soirée sur notre
antenne